so many celebrate throughout the weekend
law enforcement wants to make sure
everybody stays safe so that's why local
agencies are targeting anyone who's
driving impaired sasha loftis joins us
live with the latest on this weekend's
initiative sasha
denise and bryan 8 news now spoke with a
woman today who lost her husband in what
police are calling a dui crash officers
say they want to prevent anyone else
from experiencing this same kind of
unnecessary pain
i kept expecting him to come home joanne
erisman is forced to face devastation
few could ever imagine they said my
husband didn't even know what hit him
he died instantly steve her husband of
nearly 20 years
died in a crash right near their home on
tuesday
police say he was hit by a man speeding
and driving under the influence when
people that drink and drive they say
they're not going to do it again but
they do joanne says her life will never
be the same and she's one of so many
affected here in southern nevada in 2021
metro police say 50 people lost their
lives in dui crashes there's no excuse
ever to drive in pairs as we head
through the st patrick's day holiday
weekend trooper ashley wellman with
nevada state police says local law
enforcement agencies are joining forces
to target impaired drivers so we'll be
out there in numbers
really
present to try to make sure that we can
prevent any fatalities from happening
they hope these efforts to promote safer
roads
will keep others from experiencing this
same kind of suffering i'm just going to
miss my husband for the rest of my life
the joining forces initiative targeting
impaired drivers continues until this
tuesday march 22nd now nevada state
police will host another initiative in
april targeting distracted drivers
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now